welcome everybody if you know Nathan you
know that he always starts early so
starting on time for this conference is
starting early in a sense and that's
very consistent with Nathan so Nathan
bar is going to talk to us today he was
raised in California studied at
university of santa cruz UC santa cruz
came here in 2005 to do a masters which
means next year he should get a ten-year
pin took a year off after that and just
hadn't got enough of informatics so he
came back to do a doctoral and he's
going to tell us today of what he's
learned about situation awareness
section so colleagues fellow mentors
well this isn't it allowed to end on our
guests are a way to turn down the park
so one of the topics I'm interested in
is medication reconciliation because I
find that it's a fascinating social
phenomena this is the general outline of
my talk oh go through just the nature of
the problem that I'm looking at the
definition of situational awareness okay
the different types and the different
types and levels of situational
awareness methods involved in actually
assessing it in the wild and
applications as they relate to health
care so medication reconciliation is
this task where clinicians and
pharmacists have to resolve
discrepancies across multiple medication
list this situation arises when a
patient may visit different clinicians
or different providers and they each
maintain a unique and independent record
for them so from the patients are from
the
itions perspective they need to have
adequate knowledge about about the
patient in order to safely treat them
and avoid causing adverse events through
prescribing inter like medications that
might interact so one of the things that
arises from this sort of federated
nature of health care is that clinicians
like launched into this exquisite ballet
of information retrieval and
double-checking across records so you
know some of the common actions that
might occur is that the clinician
interviews the patient to check up with
their adherence reviews the medication
record and then digs through a huge pile
of notes to see why there might be a
discrepancy between them now one way or
like one way we might look at this
problem is through the lens of
situational awareness situational
awareness generally described is knowing
sort of what's going on in the
environment around you the aviation and
military domains have studied this
concept in an effort to understand how
it affects pilots performance and to
sort of optimize the the ability to toss
large volumes of information at them
without a without overloading their
cognitive visual function
functionalities so I think clinicians
face the same dilemma and that they need
to be able to process increasingly
larger amounts of data particularly
coming from other sources like hie s and
other professionals in order to know
what is going on with the patient so in
talking about so in the next few slides
I'll give a more in-depth description of
what situational awareness because just
describing it at the level of you know
it's knowing what's going on around us
is not sufficient for being able to
operationalize and measure the concept
as I've dug through the literature I've
notice that there are different levels
of situational awareness there's an
individual situational awareness there's
a team-based situational awareness and
there's this concept known as
distributed situational awareness at the
individual level situational awareness
describes the cognitive processes of
recognizing cues in the environment
making sense of them and using that to
prime decision-making at the team level
this refers to how two or more
individuals reach a common ground when
they are striving towards a common task
and when we get to a distributed level
the concept sort of becomes more
generalized and we we start including
objects in our model in terms of
containers or catalyst of situational
awareness knowledge or information so
one of the tricky things about
situational awareness as a concept
itself is that it is a psychological
construct that cannot be directly
measured so when we talk about it we
kind of talked about it indirectly or
using or within context to the tasks
that are being performed one of the
consequences of this abstract nature of
the of this concept is that a lot of
different researchers have developed
distinct definitions for the term one
author dominguez from the 1990s actually
identified about a dozen distinct and
unique definitions one thing that I've
noticed over the years is that the
evolution of this term it originally
started it was originally recognized by
a German military pilot in World War two
known by the name of oswald woke and he
described it as gaining superior
awareness of your surroundings before
the enemy does as we progress through
time
um the early definitions described it in
context of a flying task being aware of
objects in the environment the enemy
aircraft yourself how your plane is
flying and so on then we progress to a
more generalized concept in which it is
a process but it is a cognitive process
by which we recognize things in the
environment and then we make sense of
them so one of the early so uh I'm not
going to go over all the dammit the
different models because there are
several of them but I will sort of go
over a few of them that highlight the
points of contention with actually
defining and measuring this concept one
of the earlier representations of this
or one of the earlier researchers of
this concept was known by Taylor he
developed something called the
situational awareness rating technique
what he looked he started off with the
definition with the US Air Force's
definition of the concept in which
situational awareness was knowledge
about stuff around you and he then what
he did then was he took us several
scenarios he presented them to pilots
and had them identify scenarios which
were relevant to that concept and from
this he identified 14 categories related
to situational awareness situational
awareness itself demands on attentional
resources supply of attentional
resources and understanding of the
situation within each of these three
categories we have several subcategories
in terms of instability complexity
arousal concentration and so on these
are factors that may affect how a person
is able to achieve to achieve a greater
sense of their surroundings now the next
the next sort of big model was proposed
by ensley Endsley actually embedded the
concept of situational awareness within
a human cognitive information processing
model so as humans we have basic
resources in terms of a certain supply
of attention memory we have the
capability to make decisions that make
sense of the world so on so what she
proposed was that when we actually
perceived the world we do so in three
stages which is um we have perception we
comprehend we have some comprehension of
the situation and then we're able to
predict the behavior of the objects
we've observed or project them into the
future the interesting thing about this
models Endsley states that this is the
the state of being for the mind so
situation like one of the distinctions
she makes is that situational awareness
is a state or a product of the mind of
where we know something about the
environment and there's a process called
situational assessment in which we reach
the state of situational awareness we
might seek out information or receive it
through our visual percept assists those
the interesting thing is that I think it
kind of conflicts with the model in that
in order to perceive something that
could also be described as a process one
of the like one of the main points of
contention was has been like sort of
like what is situational awareness and
like and what are its components and one
of the biggest points of contention was
is situational awareness a process or
product Smith and Hancock argued that
there is no distinction between the two
because in order to sort of achieve
situational where in order to achieve
situational awareness you need to have
some prior awareness about the
environment so it's kind of this chicken
and the egg issue where you must already
have knowledge of
out the environment and this Prime's
your ability to sort of seek out more
information about the environment which
again Prime's your knowledge about the
environment so now I think one of the
interesting things here is that they try
to represent a more sort of they tried
to like represent situational awareness
as this very deeply complex and cyclical
model but it was there it never quite
reached the popularity of ends Lee's
model because it's very hard to
deconstruct and represent in terms of
practical research so from here I'll
dive right into team awareness in team
awareness it's this notion that you have
multiple people working together and
that that their participation in a group
produces emergent properties of
situational awareness that could not
otherwise be attributed to an individual
solace originally defined situational
awareness as the as a combination of the
individuals awareness and the team works
or team processes they participate in
ensley built our extended her model to
suggest that awareness is simply an
overlap of knowledge about a particular
task between two or more individuals and
salmon serve integrated this information
into a richer and more complex model
this is sort of saliz's representation
of team situational awareness in it we
have an individual who's participating
in part of a team they have their own
prior knowledge and their own processing
faculties and their own set of goals
these goals may be shared with other
team members as they participate in team
related tasks or processes such as
communication and coordination
one thing to note like I'm not really
very happy or like I I think that this
model has certain issues in terms that
everything is sort of deeply
interconnected so it's very hard to sort
of deconstruct how but deconstruct what
is like how situational awareness is
shared plus he also sort of mixes up the
terms of situational awareness and goal
personally I find that goal is the
desired state you want the environment
to be in and situational awareness is
the existing state so for practical
purposes I find that this model isn't
doesn't have the level of or fine like a
refined nature it's not refined enough
to use this is ends Lee's model it's a
fairly simple model in which you have
team members and they have their own
distinct awareness that enables them to
perform their tasks now they may share
or overlap they may have shared or
overlapping pieces of knowledge that
they need to be aware of in order to
perform sort of joint tasks the circles
represent those pieces of knowledge or
low gray circles and the black boxes
represent their own distinct awareness
which is separate is separate from their
other team members ensley sort of
characterized team situational awareness
as the entirety of this complex one
thing to note and a couple of other
authors have pointed this out is that
situational awareness is not simply the
summation of all the team members
awareness it it's this emergent property
of having them like of having them
understand each other and work together
this is Salmons integration of the of
the situational awareness across the
different researchers in this he
identifies team processes as leading to
a more global level of awareness amongst
all the team members so an individual
have their own sort of set of awareness
about you know the team their own goals
and their own activities and that they
as they participate in team processes
this will form a greater understanding
of what of what activities the team is
performing what goals the team has how
this sort of and this knowledge of team
situational awareness will also feed
into modifying their own their own model
of like what activities they're
performing distributed situational
awareness as I've mentioned includes the
notion that artifacts can be containers
or catalyst of information or
situational awareness knowledge a lot of
this information is an extension off of
Hodgins work in which he noticed that a
system like in order for a system
performance its task it needs all the
capabilities of its different agents so
for example i think the off sided
example is that in order for a cockpit
to figure out its speed it needs the it
needs the combination of like the speed
booklet in the the speed booklet to
specify what the ideal speeds are for
that particular aircraft and for the
particular weight and then the pilot
will markov so this is how fast you
should be flying and these are what the
wink configurations are and so on so in
this notion situational awareness can be
sort of distributed in that each in that
human agents have their own awareness of
the environment they can embed
information within other objects that
that other agents can read and sort of
learn what was going on in an indirect
fashion one of the examples provided by
believe artman and garbis was this
notion of a fireman reading a smoke
detector on building he knows there's a
[ __ ]
he knows there's a fire by the indirect
information that the smoke detectors
providing them so now artman and garbis
originally proposed this notion of
distributed situational awareness by
looking at a swedish like a swedish
emergency call centre and one of those
pictures is actually not from a Swedish
center but from the New York center but
look what I thought was a nice visual so
anyways at the center he observed he
like looked at two case studies one in
which there are two operators like one
operator was listening to a collie who
had recently stabbed herself and was
calling for medical assistant this
operator was repeating the story out
loud so that their neighbor could listen
in and indirectly get a sense of what
the situation is she wasn't directly
experiencing or getting the story from
the collie but she was receiving just
enough information to know that she
needed to call the odd the ambulance and
the fire department to get help to that
person the other case that they looked
at was in the train in the training
sessions for the Swedish call center
they would they would have the trainees
participate in bunch of task and then
write down their decisions within a
journal or a logbook and when they
reviewed this log the chief of staff
would actually go through and read the
information and recount the events as
they happened across all the different
individuals so in this case the journal
like storage situational awareness
information that the chief of staff
could not otherwise contain entirely in
their memory or be aware of as other
agents were carrying out their tasks in
another case by Stanton what he did is
he tried to develop a measure or a way
sort of operationalizing this concept of
distributed situational awareness he
wanted to move away from this concept of
sharing because he felt that sharing put
too much emphasis on having all the team
members reach sort of the same kinds of
understanding or having a homogenous
understanding among each other rather he
noted that instead each of the different
agents had a complementary piece of
information that the other required in
order to perform their tasks one of the
things he looked at was the looked at
work stations on like our simulations of
a frigate 22 in which you would have
several different military officers be
responsible for targeting assessment for
firing upon the enemy or for commanding
the battleship in this particular image
all the operators are sitting side by
side they have headphones on they are
primarily communicating through there
through their microphones and they have
sort of a distinct view of the
battlefield now sometimes these agents
will like sort of contact each other or
just look at their they're in close
proximity enough to sort of figure out
what view the other person is has and in
situations where they're seated too far
away they can simply contact each other
through the phone so or through the
microphone so in this situation the the
different the agents have a different
view they have a completely different
sense of reality but they're able to
perform their tasks by by knowing who
has what information and by having a
protocol to pass that information on to
the next person in a standardized format
now I will go into the different methods
for assessing situational awareness many
of these methods are targeted towards
assessing individual situational
awareness mostly because
that's been like more well developed so
the first method was a situational
requirements analysis this isn't
necessarily a method but it's a
prerequisite for characterizing what
situational awareness is in most of this
research since situational awareness
isn't is context dependent and it falls
to the researchers to develop sort of a
normative definition of what the task is
in order to define what information they
expect the the subject to actually be
aware of when they're when they're
studying a certain like a certain task
once that's once they have a bunch of
goals and pieces of information that
they can serve deterministically ass
Gump the subject if they're aware of or
not they have this they they use a
technique called freeze probes so in
freeze probes what you do is you stick
the subject in a high-fidelity
simulation you have them perform some
task and at random points in the
simulation you freeze the simulation and
you ask them like sort of just basic
questions or what are you aware of in
the pilot's case it's sort of like like
how many enemy aircraft are there what
is the designation of this aircraft and
so on this was a method originally used
by her it's used by a couple different
researchers but I think ensley made it
most famous in her Sagat measure the
other kind of know yeah the limitation
of the freeze probe was that you have to
interrupt the person's the person's task
and this may affect performance but the
nice thing is that you have sort of this
objective measurement of what's in the
subjects head and you can you have a
natural way of relating this to
performance like okay this person has
more situational awareness
do they have better performance or not
another approach has been to issue
real-time probes in this situation you
don't actually stop it but you just ask
the person as they're doing the task
like you know like how many patients are
you seeing right now do you know this
patient's medication and so on the
trouble the tricky part with this
approach is that it sort of falls on the
observer to develop appropriate queries
dynamically and ask the task it's being
performed another popular technique that
was developed by Taylor was self-rating
basically you have these categories of
situational awareness and a subject will
perform their task and you
retrospectively ask them okay did you
feel like you had sufficient awareness
like what do you believe was the
complexity of this task and so on one of
the drawbacks of this approach is that
it doesn't measure situational awareness
per se but it measures perception of
awareness and this has a nasty drawback
also of being correlated with
performance namely if I perform really
well then yeah I had great situational
awareness if I performed really poorly
then I didn't have good situation
where's I didn't know what's going on
let me see the other method was the the
observer rating technique this is the
one in which you have an observer
looking at the you know basically
observing a subject they have maybe a
checklist of sort of behaviors and they
tried to assess the awareness from that
perspective using their own intuition
this method requires subject mat matter
experts to actually be able to assess
the subjects the subjects awareness and
in this case it's questionable whether
they can accurately measure what's going
on in the head because there's this
unclear relationship between situational
awareness and ultimate performance
finally we have performance measure
that's in which you infer how well the
subject is performing as whether they
have good situational awareness or not
like if you have a driver and they're
avoiding a lot of different objects then
they're probably aware that those
objects are there process indices are
basically things like like verbal
protocol analysis and and I tracking
basically does it look like these person
these people are following the following
the information or looking at the right
information at the right time I think
the drawback of this is that it doesn't
necessarily assess the content or
quality of awareness but it sort of
infers it finally we have team
situational awareness measures these
refer to sort of a mixture of measures
in terms of looking at overlap in mental
models and so on one of the things about
these measures is that when we're trying
to assess situational awareness there
are certain criteria by which we are
there certain ideal criteria by which
we'd like to measure the construct
Ensley stated that what we'd want is
measures of situational awareness do not
measure other processes or factors they
possess the required level of
sensitivity and the technique can
accurately detect changes in situational
awareness caused by novel technologies
and programs and that the measure does
not alter situational awareness during
the measurement procedure so things like
freeze probes could potentially or
stopping the person in the middle of
their task could potentially disrupt
them or disrupt their awareness also
there's this notion that when we start
including a when we start measuring
properties of a team's awareness we need
more flexibility because it it ends up
being more complex are difficult to
actually freeze the team and get more
information for
so this is just an example of what the
what the so it when assessing
situational awareness there are probably
two or three popular techniques for
doing so one of them is the self rating
technique mostly because it's fairly
simple to implement and it's not
intrusive on the subjects so in this we
can take Taylor's generic set of
constructs some like what was your
demand on attentional resources what
were your resources and what was your
understanding of the situation we can
also ask them to rate their rate their
perceptions on the subcategories and
this is analyzed by summing together the
measures and then seeing if there's a
difference between a case and control
situation now again there are drawbacks
to this method because it doesn't
actually measure situational awareness
but it measures perceptions of awareness
self assessment then again may be
influenced by performance and the the
measures end up being correlated with
confidence levels and and they have
generally performed poor than other
types of measures such as sagat so Sagat
implements is a technique used by
endsley to stick the subject in a
simulation and issue freeze probes to
them randomly so the subject will see
this representation on the screen of
like what their plane is doing in a
flying task and then they'll blank the
screen and they'll ask them a series of
questions like how many planes did you
see on the screen well as their
designation what's what's the aircraft
altitude and so on in general this
method has performed very well in
actually assessing the contents of the
subjects mental models it has good
construct validity it has good
reliability and so on I think the only
drawbacks to this model well this model
is it or this measurement technique is
very popular because it's well validated
and effective but the drawbacks and
using it in a team-based situation is
that you can it's very difficult again
to freeze the team-based scenario and I
think oh and also one of the things is
that you may have difficulty in
measuring implicit information so the
distinction in situational awareness
there there may be a distinction between
implicit and explicit information in
this notion that a subject may be able
to perform their task without
necessarily being conscious or aware
that they're performing it now are they
technically aware do they have a higher
level of awareness and they skip the
lower levels of perception to get there
and so sagad and anslee's model assumes
that the subject has to go through the
lower levels of cognitive processing to
reach that stage this isn't necessarily
one technique for looking at distributed
situational awareness models this isn't
necessarily a measurement technique yet
it's more of a descriptive observational
model but standin at all proposed
looking at this notion of a
propositional network mainly what he did
was he used critical decision methods
and content analysis to develop this
large complex network up sort of this
global information space that might be
activated by different users performing
different tasks and this might give us a
sense of how awareness might be shared
or distributed between the different
agents the results are something along
these lines in which he was looking at
agents performing a military exercise of
assessing targets and
trying to determine fire control and in
this model he has certain nodes that are
activated when an agent is performing
their task and others which aren't
activated but may be related to like
what they actually need to perform now
one thing to note about this model is
it's actually very messy and a little
hard to discern what is going on one of
the other I think methods that might be
worthwhile in terms of organizing this
information that are one of our other
fellows have mentioned is this notion of
cognitive work analysis namely about if
we understand how a person performs
their tasks and like what paths they
have in strategies they have cognitive
work analysis might be a useful tool for
presenting this interrelationship
between a person performing their task
and using the resources that they have
and interacting with other agents within
their system so this is just sort of a
set of examples in terms of how
situational awareness is applied in the
in the medical field a lot of the
different studies I've looked at they've
attempted to look at team-based
situations in the ICU or are where where
they tried to assess like okay what is
the level of communication between these
issues most of the different examples
I've seen they've issued explicitly
surveys or questionnaires
retrospectively to see or to see what
their assessment of the situation is or
they've asked them what the are they
taken a look at the processes in terms
of how often they participated in team
huddles
so sorry
so in one situation the first example
wang used the combination of critical
decision method and grounded theory to
develop a descriptive model of how
dispatchers interacted with their
control systems to achieve mental like
to identify how their mental pictures
were maintained and developed and what
they discovered was that like there is a
need to sort of maintain a hub strategy
and to look at their understanding of
structural and temporal relationships
between the agents paresh try to
identify whether communication instances
the that did not have closed loop
communication events if they might
affect sort of the deterioration or the
maintenance of information so a closed
loop communication is where you send
receive and confirm that your message
has been received in their in their
study they found that believe was
sixty-three percent of team situational
awareness communication was susceptible
to information loss leader measured
process indices such as frequency
communication and team huddles to see if
they predicted a convergent or divergent
team situational awareness they
operationalize this concept as whether
the team was able to have the same
predictions of what would happen to the
patient after 48 hours so so they found
that most of the most cases the team did
not have the same pretty low the same
kinds of predictions and in cases where
they were different the senior doctors
had the most accurate representation of
what would happen to the patient over
time finely woven had
surgeons nurses and analysis and nurses
Nessus rate their perceived levels of
communication teamwork and situational
awareness the distinction they felt was
that surgeons felt that they adequately
exchanged information but everyone else
didn't so I'm not sure um and lastly
yingling performed an interesting study
in which she used retrospective probes
to see how like how aware clinicians
were of their tasks now these were these
were actually similar to the ends Lisa
got probes but she didn't have the
freedom to stop this simulation at
random points so she had to issue a
bunch of so she had an inch issue a
bunch of probes afterwards just to
assess it they found that the teams with
better communication have better had
better situational awareness and and
again yeah and I think that was it for
the studies that I've found so far so
this is sort of drawing to a conclusion
but in looking at these different
methods a lot of them are sort of
targeted to assessing an individual's
situational awareness the limitations of
those methods are that they require you
to have a subject in a high-fidelity
situation and to be able to freeze their
tasks at random points in times but for
more complex team-based situations or
scenarios in many cases the the
individual agents may not be co-located
in both time and space so this makes it
difficult to sort of take a snapshot of
the system and also most most of the
time the the freeze probes depend on
having an a priori or normative
decisions of what the tasks are
beforehand
whereas if you have a more dynamic and
richer task or ability to perform our
problem that the agent needs to be to
perform then then it's harder to sort of
create a normative definition and to ask
them questions about it so again this
may suggest that in terms of future
methods I would like to apply this to
our well and also looking back at the
clinical evidence most people assess
teams that were sort of co-located are
part of one system I think one thing
that I would like to do is to see how
situational awareness is coordinated
when the different agents of a patient's
care team are not part of the same
hospital system or they're part of
different departments that are
physically and temporally located apart
like how does this affect the team's
awareness of what is going on and what
are the processes that they use to
achieve at least a certain level of
concordance among the different agents
when the patient actually does come in
to see them I see that I may be ending
well I think that is about the end of my
presentation I would like to thank my
advisors and potential committee members
dr. Gorman and Nancy Vukovic and like
dr. Wessell raw I would like to thank
the NLM for giving me this opportunity
the faculty Adam ice Andrea Diane and
lynn 4 sort of helping me navigate the
more administrative tasks James and
beyond for sitting through most of my
questions and other colleagues and
mentors particularly the folks at the VA
for letting me look at some of their
pharmacist data
thank you okay we invite everyone's
questions Nathan thank you however the
question comes up why is medication
reconciliation a hard problem um because
you have agents working like I think
it's because of the affordances of the
workplace basically you have agents
working apart from one another they have
different goals and tasks in mind that
they're trying to perform in making the
patient well they don't have necessarily
the clearest channels of communication
they may be communicating indirectly
through the patient as they come in with
their discharge summary from last time
and this may not give the the clinician
who's seen them currently the requisite
information to decide whether this
information is correct enough today so
they have to do a little bit more
detective work to just assess the
validity of the information that they
have at hand yes okay I have two
questions you can pick which one the
first one is we use aviation a lot to
compare to healthcare and I'm curious in
your reading do you think it does that
comparison hold up is it instructive for
things like primary care not just what
goes on in a small care team like an
operating room I think it's for me I
find it a little bit harder to directly
apply the models of aviation because I
think that part of the work domain that
is the most dynamic and unpredictable is
the patient and that changes on a
case-by-case basis whereas in aviation
and flying you have a plane you know
you're flying the plane you know you're
flying it through the sky so a certain
amount of the task is actually fixed and
can actually be tested with respect to
that whereas if we want to apply
situational awareness concepts to the
health care field it would be useful to
incorporate the dynamic nature of the
patient into that model
so following up on James's question in
the [ __ ] that they're co-located yes in
medicine they're not well tab is that
necessary in primary care they're not so
how does that affect what we're doing so
there are a couple ways to look at this
technically yes the pilot and co-pilot
are co-located but they're not
co-located with the air traffic control
but they still have to coordinate their
activity with them and air traffic
control has to intern coordinate both
that flights activity and the activity
of all of the other flights but I think
for the most part when people are
studying these distributed models
they're simply looking at a cockpit or
an icy or team-based situation I think
it's a matter of choosing the
appropriate unit of analysis and I think
one of the things that we tend to have a
habit in terms of analyzing is like the
team a clinical team that's co-located
it's part of the same system they have
the same objectives and norms but I
think one of the interesting things that
probably isn't studied well enough is
this notion of what is the care team
from the patient's perspective because
that may be because the that may be sort
of more dynamic but there may be some
level of coordination that we have an
explorer tour that we don't quite
understand yet anyone else yes just just
a bit of a follow-on of how it using
situational awareness actually improve
medication reconciliation so there's
this one concept that i like it comes
more so from the engineering field goods
if you can't measure it you can't
control it so i think one of the first
steps in sort of improving the design of
systems for health care is being able to
measure the system's effect on the
clinicians situational awareness and
then once we can actually have a
measurable construct then we can try out
different design
calls and see if they improve or dis
improve it thank you easy one and this
is a legitimate question situation
awareness or situational awareness
that's actually a hard question um I've
seen I've seen them used interchangeably
I suspect it's more of a stylistic
choice that is used between like
depending on how you form the sentence
so yeah okay well I guess thank you